and then he's laughing saying yes sir
seriously i'm not doing so well right
now you got to bring those up and uh you
seem to have settled yourself collected
a couple of wins
yeah we're happy like uh now it's like
two games in a row so it's good yeah
good trend indeed what does she go wrong
in this game
i don't know really no i think maybe
she didn't like find the best way how to
react on my five move i think yeah it
was always in the era we're thinking
this move and it was like the best time
to play probably she had to take and it
would be equal position
so i
i had feeling that after five i have
some chances right we saw this move come
in very sharply we weren't paying too
much attention to but i didn't notice
when you played it and it just looked
like white had
some initiative here and she played
knight e4 yeah i think it probably was
better to take and play
oh yeah and trying to hold okay it's
slightly better but it's not easy to
convert
right something like that it would be a
safe way but it's not her style
and
i assume especially in being in time
pressure in this situation
but speaking honestly speaking honestly
after queen d2
i had feelings that i have win after but
um
could you please go back when i played
queen queen e2 allowing to play knight
c3 right at this moment
yes
here nice history and do i have win here
if night cesary
i was thinking about queen g4
and can she take and i i did i didn't
see like clear win after uh taking a
rook
taking only six and uh yes can get shade
so it looks like very dangerous i have
like many moves
yes exactly what to what to do i wasn't
yeah if i go
so tell yes sir no
no
no
oh no
the desirable stare of um yeah
that is not there yes yes i had feelings
that feel like my attack can be strong
i may have something but i didn't see we
don't we refuse well let's okay it does
look like it's hard how about
no no but the problem is if i go on the
other square then
he always has this ni king of eight move
maybe i go on g5 i take on h7 and just
continue attack
in this case okay in this case
yes this is a problem no there's no no
here is
no but it looks very dangerous and i
thought maybe she will like one thing
she may afraid to go to this position
and second maybe if i will get to this
position i will find something here
so you're thinking
somehow yes something like that that was
my idea and that i realized if this
position will come on the board i will
calculate and think yeah
okay let's go back for a second so if
you go bishop takes h7 after king g8
does that work
here and this bishop takes h7 yeah
and where are you chasing the king you
chase the king out so knight g5 queen h3
very interesting yeah
no uh we're thanking christians
yes yes i think it's amazing it wasn't
made here this looks dangerous i mean
this looks checked yeah maybe or maybe
you can second it's just winning i
calculated it is winning so it's wow
what did you get in g7 queen g7 here yes
king d6 doesn't do it question this six
is not okay q and g this is winning yeah
this is checkmate right queen that's
enough i have like plenty of pawns for
the queen this is what's winning yeah
that's our thinking now
so maybe this move yeah well the
question is after bishop page seven king
f8 but i think nice no no but this is
this is just film that all my pieces are
taking king and uh
must be winning probably yeah yeah this
is winning this is weird if she can't
play king h7 she would have to play king
of eight 95 and now you're threatening
several different ways of
winning yes looks like over your
intuition yeah that's right
i i saw it at least i have perpetual and
intuition gave me this so
that's it it could be something right
well you you you left it late but 93 she
does that she doesn't have to accept
right
she can't uh take on b1 but i guess in
this situation i will be just like
like better with such natural name five
yeah
right queen
oh no no here he would
if i don't have anything better than
rookie one will just strategically much
better position for me right
so it didn't have to happen but it could
yes yeah
especially if you wanted to make our
brilliancy segments
brilliant surprise
now that she heard it did you see her
wait a minute
they would i would ask probably sabina
during the game too
did you see the way
there's a brilliant surprise that would
be second pieces the next two games no
no we have a segment called brilliancy
versus blunder and we choose
the brilliance the the brilliant play
from the previous round and also the
blunders from the pre previous round i
don't know
i don't think any of yours made the
segment i'm not sure i remember any yes
uh anna
brilliancy reprises cash prizes we
reserve for the commentators where we
find the brilliant moves that have been
missed i guess christian just won one
right
here's one one guess is paying for
thanks so much for joining us and we
hope to see more brilliant play from you
in the next two rounds yeah thank you
well done